if you look down the end of the carpet
you'll see my wig because it flew off
when you guys showed up before on do you
need one babies caught up this I know
this is like if Charo took a lot of hair
and nail vitamins rose here she just
says she's about to announce a new show
what do you got you guys got to be on it
I think yes we're executive producers
yeah yeah it's a cooking sell a cooking
show and everything's charred char oh I
love that you guys a show is bad I mean
why was it time to return to this format
we can do whatever we want
yeah we can say whatever we want and
where it's more free yeah that's the
beauty of being on YouTube it's all
self-starters and you get to walk into
work and decide we're gonna do that day
nobody's in charge of it well so in that
case is there a top that you guys won't
ever touch or is anything off limits
like always wanted to talk about suicide
a little grim but I think we could
lighten it up we specialize in taking
very grim and making it of small bites
you know are you tonight I can't
lifestyle lifestyle I all are you in the
lifestyle you know are you I'm not I
mean I'll be like if I get through that
door you know did you guys go through
security today I got pat-down oh I have
a steel bone corset on and I went
through it and the beeper didn't go off
so everybody here could have a gun
gotcha
Trixie said working with you was one of
the most meaningful things in her life I
mean what does that feel like to hear
that the rest of my life of perspective
sounds like a depressing life she's
having
Minny aim high or with the goal yeah you
guys make a pretty damn good team what's
it like sharing this whole thing
together it's it's nice to be a team
yeah it gets lonely she can count on me
and I can also count on me okay I know
you took some time off of yourself this
year like what did you learn what it
costs you learn about Katya and that I'm
actually a size 12 not a size 9 and that
I speak Chinese yeah you can't do
anything I can can she do walk a line
stop sweating that is the team you're
talking to the sweatiest woman in the
green screen show business what are you
sweating everything everywhere all the
time we do not have premium
air-conditioning we don't have like the
Tyler Oakley central air we don't have
the jenna Marbles icebox no [ __ ]
grace helbig lighting Oh [ __ ] we got
two in a barn light and a green bucket
of paint and this barely hanging on real
quick Trixie you're a cartoon now I am I
mean tell us about the show well I'm on
super dry food a Netflix this month and
I play I actually I'm the youngest in
the cast but I play the older character
so that's me very self-conscious about
my own voice because apparently I sound
old I think I just sound over it it
sounds like an iconic animated character
though well II don't she look like Katja
just she was like I'm out oh she's like
two questions bye and now we're done
back to the studio Bob
you
[Music]